so hello welcome my name is Rafael at
Santini I'm a faculty member here in the
Linguistics Department when I started
playing in this event with the help of
some of our students I had two goals in
mind
I thought we will learn we wanted to
learn more about ASL and about sign
languages in general their structure
their history their importance and we
also wanted to celebrate the fact that
now ASL is a subject of study at Yale so
students can learn the language and be
exposed to issues relevant to the deaf
community
but as we organize the event and got in
touch with a number of people at Yale we
also realized that this gave us the
opportunity to do something else to meet
members of the deaf community at Yale
and Beyond Yale and to give them an
opportunity to meet one another this is
wonderful because it shows that
introducing as ASL at Yale is not only
interesting and useful but it also helps
us create a more inclusive and diverse
community and this is something that
enriches all of us so I'm happy to see
you all here I'd like to welcome all of
you our panelists and our interpreters
and we're going to start with some
opening remarks from three people who
represent three different groups at Yale
administration staff and faculty so the
first one is Dean George Levesque from
the Yale College dean's office
thank you very much I really just have a
few words of welcome that I want to
extend on behalf of the Yale College
dean's office I know that we have many
people from sorry is this better
we have I know many people from across
the university you are here today and I
understand we have some colleagues from
other institutions too who have joined
us on campus thank you for coming and
helping to be a part of this
special thanks to our presenters who
have prepared our program for this
afternoon I also want to take this
moment to publicly thank a number of
critical partners across the campus who
have been instrumental as professors an
attorney mentioned of bringing ASL into
the ELL college curriculum I want to
begin by thanking professors Anna tunia
who has director of undergraduate
studies of linguistics was a persistent
and eloquent champion for ASL to come
into the curriculum professor frank his
chair of linguistics it was critically
important to us in the dean's office
that ASL have a departmental home within
the Faculty of Arts and Sciences and so
it has been very important for a
linguistics to provide the departmental
home and structure for for ASL we think
that we thank you for that I thank
jessica tanner for who has taught ASL
through our directed independent
language study program our Dill's
program you may hear about that a little
bit later we have been teaching ASL
informally through that program for a
number of years and jessica has been
very instrumental in that in developing
a loyal following of students and I also
want to thank my colleague who couldn't
be here today I'm sorry I'm not oka Ben
Doozer nursery school who as director of
the Center for language study supports
Dill's and funds that program so I thank
you thank her in her absence and lastly
a few more people
you don't mind my colleagues on the
language Study Committee and in the
teaching resource Advisory Committee
when we received the proposal from
linguistics it was immediately and
enthusiastically supported by the
members of the committee it was it was
really heartening to see faculty from
across a number of departments
immediately jump on board is this an
opportunity to bring ASL into the
curriculum and none of this would not
have been possible without the support
of the Dean of the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences Tamar Gendler who received the
recommendation from the language Study
Committee and the teaching resource
Advisory Committee and she also warmly
received it and found funding for it for
the inaugural teaching position so we
thank her for for that support and last
but not least I want to thank the past
and current students who have expressed
this abiding interest in studying ASL
for a variety of reasons he goes without
saying that we wouldn't be able to offer
courses in ASL if there are no students
who are interested in taking them and
this has been a wild success to see the
number of students in our opening
sections of ASL bursting at the scenes
has been very gratifying not only to
prepare them I'm sure as as citizens in
a more diverse world but just a vital
and robust intellectual field of study
that ASL is and so we're very happy on
behalf of the Yoko's dean's office
behalf of York College to welcome you
all here thank you for coming and enjoy
the afternoon thank you
[Applause]
the next speaker giving some welcoming
remarks is Cindy Greenspun thank you for
having me here
my name is Cindy gangbang I worked that
year for 20 years I worked for the year
library sector
I've been depth all of my life I lost my
hearing 102 years old I was mainstreamed
in the public to detect them and often
out the only deaf person in those hoods
that I've attended it was a struggle to
keep up with my classmates and my grades
were nothing to be proud of
I made it to college and my idea was
also a struggle until I realized that if
I'm in sign language
I might get the help and the support
that I need to keep up with my
classmates so I made it a goal to learn
sign language and the next semester I'm
happy to be put to our review that for
the rest of my semester in college my
grades were ready I was terrified it
American Sign Language it amazing it was
even more amazing in am really grateful
if that American Sign Language a part of
the curriculum idea and I hope that it
is a beautiful helpful to other who
might be in the same situation as I or
to anybody here and go now so thank you
for all of your hard work to everybody
to the Yale community who have been done
angry to the University thank you
[Applause]
Bob Frank who's the chair of the
linguistics department so I would like
to welcome everybody who's here and and
thank thank our speakers for coming and
for sharing what I'm sure will be a
fascinating afternoon I'd also like to
echo the thanks that Dean Levesque made
earlier which actually I have exactly
the same individuals listed on that
paper in front of me that I will not
repeat them for you but thank you to
everybody who's been involved in this
extremely vital and important initiative
in increasing diversity at Yale in a
very important way by incorporating ASL
and deaf culture to studies at Yale
University so one of the things that
Dean Levesque mentioned was that it was
really crucial in bringing ASL studies
to Yale was for ASL to have a
departmental home and the question of
where that should be was in a sense for
linguists and easy question that we were
very very enthusiastic if all of our
colleagues were enthusiastic about being
that home because of the importance of
the study of sign language to the study
of language in general from the
perspective of understanding the nature
of linguistic structure the study of
sign language is an important domain of
inquiry because one is tempted to try to
relate the nature of language to the
fact that it is spoken and so one is
tries to derive in part some of the
linguistic structure from the
constraints that are imposed by the need
to speak or they need to hear and sign
language poses an interesting an
interesting alternative in that the
different modality that is used for its
speaking and perception raises other
kinds of issues and raises the question
of well is sign language just
fundamentally of a different sort and
what has been discovered
the work over the last almost half
century now has been that essentially
know that what we learned from sign
language is that there's fundamentally a
commonality in human experience in the
human mind that tells us that sign
language is a language and its structure
and its underlying cognitive mechanisms
are the same as those involved in in
spoken language and that's been
profoundly important I think both within
linguistics but also in understanding
our shared humanity
the second area in which sign language
has been scientifically significant has
comes about as the result of some
distinctive issues that arise in the
experience of the deaf community some of
these are extremely exciting issues
other things are unfortunate in the in
the deaf experience so because of the
unique experience of many deaf
individuals not being exposed to sign
language until later in life this allows
the study of unique experiences that are
characteristic of what happens to
individuals when they're not exposed to
a language until later in life and how
does that impact the way in which they
learn language so these kinds of studies
have been extremely important and have
been very enlightening um in fact our
first speakers will not transition our
first speaker today will be telling us
something about this kind of unique
experience that arises in sign language
in this case in the domain of Nicaraguan
sign which is our first speaker and
Mariko Cobb got her PhD from Harvard in
psychology in 2017 she is now continues
at at Harvard as a postdoc working
jointly with Jessie Snedeker who's a
professor in the psychology department
and our own former postdoc Kate Davidson
now of the Harvard linguistics
Department Ann Marie's work is a sort of
remarkable example of someone who
combines in an exciting way a careful
and refined understanding of the dome of
linguistic structure and the the
dimensions of variation that inform what
what goes into linguistic structure
together with
profound understanding of the cognitive
foundations of the cognitive factors
that are involved in language learning
and in language change much of her work
has studied the unique experience of
signers in Nicaragua where a new sign
language has come into being in the last
in the recent past and so she has
focused on this case study of language
emergence over the short talk short term
looking at a variety of questions from
referential shift to the formation of
questions to the existence of recursive
structures
she's also looked at a variety of other
factors including the representation of
toe Lissa tea and the use of non manual
markers and iconicity so it's a real
great pleasure for us to have professor
dr. Co cab join us and give us our first
talk today so welcome
[Applause]
thank you for that wonderful
introduction and thank you for having me
here it's very exciting event and thank
the organizers for planning all of this
language is universal and ubiquitous all
human societies in the world have a
language the question is where does
language come from there are two kinds
of explanations that are not mutually
exclusive one is that the structure of
language comes from biological evolution
and reflects properties of our cognitive
architecture how our brains have evolved
the second is that language reflects a
product of cultural evolution so the
kind of human capacity for social
learning and cultural transmission
here we have a timeline that helps us to
understand these explanations the dotted
line in the center represents the time
when Homo sapiens dispersed from Africa
around at least 70,000 years ago because
all humans have language any mechanism
that allows us to acquire language must
have been in place before we migrated
Out of Africa on the first explanation
where the structure of language comes
from biological evolution we have a
timeline like this on the y-axis we have
linguistic resources and on the x-axis
we have time on this position over
thousands of years evolution selects for
adaptations that allow for human
language creation meaning any individual
mind is capable of creating an acquiring
language on the other extreme language
comes from cultural processes similar to
how mathematics and science were
constructed over thousands and thousands
of years with each generation building
on the work of the previous generation
so getting data to help us address these
questions the question of biological
versus cultural evolution is difficult
and most languages have been around for
hundreds of thousands of years and their
patterns of emergence are largely lost
to time but we do have several tools to
help us get at this question one of
which is the study of emerging languages
in this talk I'll be talking about one
particular language in Nicaragua if you
go to Nicaragua today you'll see a
community that looks like many other
language communities if you go to a
School for the Deaf you'll see the
children they're hanging out playing and
interacting all in sign language that
language didn't exist 40 years ago
because it emerged so recently the
people who created the language are
still alive today and we can study them
to better understand where language
comes from
let me tell you a little bit about the
history of Nicaraguan sign language you
may know that most deaf children are
born to hearing parents who do not know
sign language meaning that they have no
accessible language in their environment
that was the situation in Nicaragua
until the 1970s in those situations deaf
individuals are propelled by a social
desire to communicate with other people
and they'll create gestural systems
called home sign systems to use with
their family members these systems are
internal to the family they're not used
outside of the family the situation in
Nicaragua changed drastically in the
1970s when the government established a
school for past special education that
pulled together deaf children in large
numbers for the first time this they did
not use sign language as a method of
instruction in school they used oral
methods but the children brought with
them their individual home sign systems
and began to gesture to communicate
which other on the playground and the
bus and at that point language began to
emerge and develop we call the first
group of children to enter the school
the first cohort what allowed the
language to continue to grow
is that another group of children
additional groups of children 10 that
continued to enter the school and
learned their language from the first
group of children for the purposes of
comparison how the language has changed
over time we divided these children into
groups of roughly 10 year increments the
second group is the second cohort and
then the third cohort came in each
cohort represents a successive time
point in the development of the language
not all deaf individuals enter the deaf
community there are many who never learn
a sign or spoken language so their home
sign systems remain their primary mode
of communication these systems represent
the kinds of systems that individuals in
isolation come up with I'm going to show
you brief snapshots of what Nicaraguan
sign language looks like I know you
don't know NSF I'll be telling you what
to look for in each clip the first video
that I show you will be the language of
the first cohort of signers you'll see
that their signs are larger slower
measured and there's not a lot of turn
rapid turn taking
now I'll show you the language of the
second cohort these signers as children
learned their language from the first
cohort and you'll see that their
language looks different it's faster
there's more rapid turn taking
and now I'll show you a video of the
cohort three signers who learned their
language from the second cohort their
language looks very different it's even
faster there's a lot of simultaneous
communication going on in Iraq very
interactive
as you might suspect biology alone and
culture alone can't fully explain what
we've seen so far with the first three
cohorts of NSL signers it seems that
language does not take hundreds of
thousands of years to develop but also
does not arise immediately in the first
generation fully formed we see fast
emergence of words and the linguistic
capacity to express propositions so the
story is partly biological but as this
research program has developed over the
last 20 to 30 years we found that some
linguistic structures take additional
time to develop
for example the marking of argument
structure which indicates who did what
to whom these intergenerational
processes happen rather quickly in
contrast to the typical construe love
caucus flow of cultural processes as
long and protracted ones therefore we
have a third alternative the pattern of
language emergence looks rather like
this where we have contributions from
biology that equip our minds to create
language with cultural interaction that
allows for further linguistic devices to
develop let's zoom in for a moment
on the x-axis we have the home signers
here because these are systems that
represent the kind of systems that
individuals who come up with these as a
consequence of biology and living in
human society the first three cohorts
are placed here these boxes are some of
the things that we've seen develop as
NSL has developed in change i'm not
going to talk about all of these things
but you do see that some things come up
in home sign systems some emerge in the
first cohort of signers as soon as the
community forms and other things take
more time to develop in today's talk I'm
going to talk about two specific
projects in which I've looked at this
linguistic structure of NSF recursion
and quantifiers these case studies show
how studying sign language can help us
understand more about language itself
and how it emerged these cases are
interesting to linguists because these
are places where the mapping between
syntax and semantics becomes complex the
first project I'm going to look at is
the evolution the historical evolution
of recursion which is proposed to be a
property of all human languages you can
think about recursion at two levels you
take the sentence John knows Mary knows
Bill lied on the meaning side we have a
knowledge state John's with another
knowledge state embedded in it marries
with the third event Bill's lying
embedded in that on the level of syntax
we have a simplified phrase structure
with a clause embedded within a clause
with yet another clause embedded in it
so recursion is argued to allow language
to have discrete infinity where you
could compose an infinite number of
utterances with a finite set of words
and rules
recursion is often thought to be
universal and ubiquitous and some have
made the strong claim that it's the only
thing that separates human language from
animal communication systems at least
one language has been argued to lack
recursion piraha in the Amazon instead
of producing embedded structures piraha
is argued to use para taxes so instead
of saying something like John's sister's
house which is embedded in English they
would instead produce a flat structure
with no embedding John has a sister that
sister has a house this claim is debated
part of the difficulty is the difficulty
of interpreting a lack of evidence and
also there are differences in opinion on
how the language is analyzed so we're at
an impasse is recursion a fundamental
property of human language we designed
studies to go in and analyze Nicaraguan
signer like sign language signers and
home signers to find out we looked at if
recursive structures are available to
specify a previously mentioned character
to pick them out from a set of
previously mentioned characters to pick
out a specific individual from a
previously mentioned set of characters
so that function is often accomplished
in language through the use of relative
clauses where you have a clause embedded
in another clause we designed events and
showed movies to our participants I'm
using still pictures for the sake of
time the first condition was designed to
elicit relative clauses you have a set
of girls each doing something different
and then one of the girls does something
new the target description be something
like the girl who was drawing removed
the picture
the second condition was designed to
elicit conjoin clauses by removing the
other two characters we expect to elicit
descriptions with a flat structure
without embedding a girl drew and then
removed the picture
the third condition had the same
character performing the same action
twice drawing on a piece of paper and
then drawing on an easel pad relative
clauses are not the only way to describe
these stimuli a person could use para
taxes instead where they mention the
girl and the action twice the girl drove
drew the girl removed the picture that's
the kind of structure that we would
expect if the language lacks recursion
like what we see in piraha we predict
that if the language has recursion then
the ability to convey embedded messages
would be there we expect to them pretty
bruised produce utterances that have the
meanings of relative clauses to
establish a set of characters and then
pick out an individual from that set and
predicates something new about that
individual on the syntax side prior
observation of NSL allows us to prick
predict what relative clauses might look
like many sign languages do not use
complementizer x' like who to mark
relative clauses but verbs and sign
language can chain make more full
morphological changes in size and
duration in motion so we expect that the
verb when it's embedded will be shorter
and faster compared to verbs that occur
in non embedded context providing
specific visual evidence of embedding
I'm going to show a video of a signer
who does exactly that you'll see that
she first establishes a set picks out
one person and then says something new
about that person and when she describes
that she repeats the verb it's smaller
and faster than the first time that she
describes it I'll show you the videotape
it slowed down
it has glosses for your convenience
I'm gonna play it again did I want
everyone to see that eating the Apple
the second time was shorter so let's
watch it again
that kind of description is our
candidate relative clause where signers
establish the set and then pick out an
individual the underlined section is
specifically is our relative clause with
the repeated verb we saw the signers
from all three cohorts produce those
kind of repeated strings on the relative
Clause trials but not in the other two
conditions we interpreted this as a
relative clause rather than para taxes
for two reasons the first is that in
theory that string could be considered
as conjunction but that interpretation
is unlikely in this context because the
verb eating an apple has already been
completed and it's already been
mentioned and therefore it's relevant
only to the extent to which it
identifies the girl under discussion in
the second reason is because the verb
itself looks different when it's
embedded in the relative clause as
opposed to when it appears in a
conjoined clause we looked at the form
of the verb in the two conditions we
quantified that to quantify this we took
the ratio of the length of the first
verb draw to the second verb remove the
picture and what we found is that the
verb draw is shorter when it's in the
relative clause as you can see by the
smaller purple bar compared to when it
appears in the conjoined clause where
you see by the longer purple bar so we
suspect that the shortening is a more
full syntactic way of marking embedding
to make sure that the shortening isn't
happening anytime the same verb is
repeated we looked at the repeated
action condition where we had the same
person doing the same action twice
drawing and drawing and we do not see
any shortening of the verb there so it
seems the shortening is specifically
incurs when a verb is embedded
so that raises the question can
individuals who have not been part of a
language community produced relative
clauses we tested adult home signers in
nicaragua and i would remind you that
these are individuals who have never
learned a sign or spoken language and
their home sign systems remain their
primary mode of communication we tested
for adult Nicaraguan home signers and
first we checked shirt to make sure they
understood the task to see if they
describe the target character and the
critical action and they all did when we
look at the descriptions in the
different conditions we see a different
pattern compared to the Nicaraguan sign
language users on the relative clause
trials the home centers did not
introduce the set or repeat the
identifying verb in fact their
descriptions looked very similar to what
we see in the conjoined clause
descriptions where they describe the
target character and the new action only
the verbs don't look any different in
these conditions either so there are
three possible interpretations of this
finding the first is that perhaps home
signers are in producing embedded verbs
but they're not marking them with the
shortening the second possibility is
maybe that home signers can't conceive
of recursive expressions the third
possibility is that home signers have
recursion in mind but they're using para
taxes to communicate based on prior work
on the kinds of messages that home
signers are able to convey we suspect
that the third hypothesis is the correct
one so that home centers do have
recursion in mind but they produce
paratactic utterances similar to what we
see in other languages that are argued
to lack recursion like para ha
so we see that the basic ability to
produce recursion is present very early
in the emergence of a new language all
NSL signers across all three cohorts
differentiate between embedded and
non-embedded contexts home signers do
not they may be using para taxes so what
allows recruit recursion that's present
to be present in cohort 1 signers but
not in home signers a key difference
between those two groups is that cohort
1 signers are part of a language
community they have the opportunity to
interact with their peers and to use
their peers utterances as input to their
own so it's possible that the home sign
messages that had embedded meaning
became input to deaf children who then
reanalyzed the language to create new
linguistic structures now I'm going to
move on to the second part that are the
second project looking at quantifiers
quantifiers and natural languages
Express a range of the range of
properties between the relationships
between properties like some birds are
flying quantifiers allow us to form
generalizations like most bananas are
clones maist maybe most maybe all
languages do have quantifiers so maybe
there's something special about
quantifiers that can help us understand
more about human cognition we tested
this by looking at quantifiers in the
first three cohorts of Nicaraguan sign
language users
as I said quantifiers express the
relationship between two properties so
we elicited quantifiers by showing
signers pictures with large sets of
individuals like bears then we show them
two paired pictures one is a subset
where a subset is engaging an entirely
new activity in this case swimming and
the difference is the size of the subset
so we would expect something like some
of the bears are swimming and here we
would expect all of the bears are
swimming here's another example intended
to elicit different quantifiers by
contrast we would get descriptions like
none of the boys climb the tree and here
we could get many of the birds flew away
we looked at three types of quantifiers
Universal quantifiers which are used
when every member of that set satisfies
the proposition all it's really given
any X property P is true I'm going to
show you an example of a sign from
Nicaraguan sign language for all it's
very fast all that's just their sign for
all the second quantifier that we
elicited were existential quantifiers
where the propositional function holds
true of at least one member of the set
many some a few a little
technically an existential quantifier
can be used in a context that it would
be described by universal quantifier for
example if all the boys climb the tree
it's also true that some of the boys
climb the tree but that tends to be less
pragmatically preferred and the reverse
is not true you can't say all of the
boys climb the tree if only some of them
did here's an example of one sign for
the quantifier many innocent many the
last quantifier type that we elicited is
negative quantifiers the negative of an
of the negation of an existentially
quantified statement so it's not the
case that member pitas property X this
is an example of the sign for none in
NSF none
for the results I'm gonna start with
existential quantifiers first on the
x-axis we have cohort and on the y-axis
we have the trials the colors represent
different quantifier types yellow is for
negative quantifiers like none Green is
for existential quantifiers like many
and blue is for Universal quantifiers
like all and what we see here is that
when signers see a picture designed to
elicit as extension Juana fires like
this they produce existential
quantifiers many birds flew away now I'm
going to show you the results for the
negative quantifiers these were just
designed to elicit things like none of
the boys climb the tree the colors mean
the same thing as they did before the
yellow bar means that we see a lot of
use of negative quantifiers across all
three cohorts we also see some
occurrences of existential and universal
quantifiers when we look more closely at
those types of description they were
using them paired with different
predicates many of the boys were
standing instead of none of the boys
climbed the tree which is a perfectly
acceptable way of describing that
picture but it's important that they do
have negative quantifiers in all three
codes now I'll show the pattern for
universal quantifiers all
we'll see a different pattern here we
see that the first cohort signers tend
to use existential quantifiers in
context that were its preferential to
use universal so if you see a picture
where all of the boys climb the tree
they tend to say many boys but the
younger signers from cohorts 2 & 3 tend
to use more Universal quantifiers all
the boys climb the tree the use of the
existential quantifier as I mentioned
before is not strictly wrong it's true
that there are many of the boys climb
the tree but it's under informative a
strong statement would be better all the
boys for example if I told you that I
ate some of the cake but in fact I eat
all of it you might be mad at me because
you thought where's my cake one possible
interpretation of this pattern is that
the pragmatic process that underlie
quantification is something that takes
time to develop in a new language for
future work we'd like to pursue this
further and we also plan to take a look
at this in home signers to understand if
quantifiers is something that people who
are not in a language community can
express like stay tuned
so we see evidence for quantifiers in
language in early and NSL which suggests
that quantifiers could be a universal
aspect of language that emerges early in
a newly developing language I started my
talk with the question where does
language come from and I hope that
you've learned from this that the study
of emerging sign languages really can
help us address this question this work
just demonstrated several different
things first humans are very well
equipped to create language and the
moment we have the opportunity to do it
we do so and build a language secondly
old language does not spring from a
single child
there are many domains that require time
or other structures to emerge but it
doesn't take hundreds of thousands of
years otherwise we wouldn't see them
here thirdly the situation in Nicaragua
is rare and important and we have an
opportunity to see the emergence of a
language in real-time that language
occurred when deaf children were bought
brought together in a school what's
interesting is that that situation is
not that unique many sign languages
around the world develop in that way so
in this in the next talk by dr. Amber
Martin she'll be discussing some of the
effects of language deprivation I want
to highlight here that children are
capable of amazing things if you just
give them the opportunity thank you
[Applause]
thank you all for coming thank you for
the to my pertness participants my
funders and my collaborators we have
about 10 minutes for questions and we
have microphones so raise your hand and
we will bring you the microphones thank
you that was that was wonderful I wanted
to go back to something that you were
pointing out towards the end and the
quantifier study and as as you know a
lot of psycholinguistic work has tended
to show that in truth value tasks
children tend to be more logical as
Novick and his colleagues put it than
adults in the sense that children are
more likely to judge sentences true if
they have the form some of the boys left
even though all of them did and adults
are much more likely to take the upper
bounding implicature into consideration
interpreting some as some but not all
and therefore rejecting sentences like
some of the boys left if all of them did
so in a sense as the cohort one turns
into cohort two we have a case of
ontogeny recapitulates phylogeny in the
sense that the the development of the
language mirrors the development within
individuals that's very true and that's
something that we've thought about one
thing that I would point out that's a
bit different is that typically these
children comprehend the time don't these
the tasks with children are
comprehension tasks but typically what
they produce sentences they're not using
under informative messages they tend to
express all which and that's different
from this these are production tasks so
there does seem to be a parallel
but there's something different going on
here potentially thank you so paranoid
that across different modalities than a
production versus comprehension thank
you hi that was a great talk so we know
in the early work by sang Haas and
Coppola that NSL signers used to use
peritectic structures for to animate
arguments so things like women push man
fall yes and people have interpreted it
as that transitivity hadn't emerged yet
in the language and that they prefer to
use paratactic structures I don't know
if you have any ideas about why there
seems to be like discrepancy between
being able to embed with like relative
causes across all cohorts but there was
this earlier finding about not being
able to have to animate arguments in the
single predicate I want to modify a
little bit so they didn't say that they
can't express transitive sentences it's
that when there are two animate
arguments it seems to be that each
argument gets its own verb so man push
woman be pushed and that's a perfectly
fine description so the argument
expression wait does that match your
understanding of their work I wouldn't
say that they don't have the capacity to
express transitive sentences I don't
really have a stance on them I just know
that as one of the interpretations of
their findings from I think other people
I think the question of why do things
appear early why do they come up early
and other things come up later right now
we don't know enough and I think this is
work that will show where we study
different domains to understand how the
language structure emerges and give it
some comparison studies between home
signers and NSL signers but they can
express transitive sentences so I want
to make sure that that important point
is made clearly thank you I just have
one more so in your slides you mentioned
spatial agreements and using space for
grammar by the third cohort but you
didn't include person agreement is there
any specific reason why because we
haven't researched that yet but it's a
great area for future research
absolutely and actually I have a study
that is going in that direction at some
point but yes person agreement that's
interesting
it was a question over here to the right
hmm oh we need an interpreter to voice
her question no okay
I was just looking at your slide about
quantitative qualifiers and on Universal
for the third cohort there it for the
second cohort you see them entirely
using Universal when Universal is what's
aimed targeted however for the third
cohort some go back to existential and I
was wondering if you had a theory as to
why that might be I suspect that's
probably just a measurement error I
think we may have less signers in that
cohort maybe right I have to look more
closely at it but it's possible that
when this the signer was describing
another picture but at this point I'm
not likely inclined to think that that's
a meaningful difference but if it is
then of course that'd be something to
look into but I suspect that it's not
good question though thank you for
asking about that Thanks
thank you very much this is very
interesting I had a question about the
relative clause findings where you
showed that there was a significant
difference in the length of the verb but
you had also mentioned and it was
evident in the video that in the the
embedded context the movement of the
verb was repeated fewer times which
makes sense you need a longer time to
have more movements in there but I
wondered if you had coded for anything
other than length and whether there were
other findings as well that we're not
significant no we coded only for length
and I'm not sure that I meant to say
that the movement of the sign itself was
less I the sign happens more quickly so
rather than some saying eat apple with a
larger movement it was as much smaller
it could be that there's the same number
of movements it's just that it's there's
this distance involved and it it's
faster to complete one thing that we
plan to do but have not yet looked at is
to take a look at the non manual markers
so non manual markers for those of you
don't know our grammatical features of
sign languages that tend to carry a lot
of information for it on the face for
example in American Sign Language we
mark conditionals like if with raised
eyebrows if it rains class will be
canceled and if there was no eyebrow
raised it would mean that it's a
declarative sentence instead it rain and
classes cancel so we plan to take a look
at those kind of markers with this data
because non-manual markers tend to go
along with crow relative clauses in many
sign languages thank you that would be
very interesting to hear about
hi thank you for coming and speaking
please bear with me while I try to
formulate this question thank you
I noticed in the slides trying to figure
when I'm watching the different slides
about the was it bears swimming
yeah the quantifiers yeah thank you
right what I noticed there were one of
the images showed the birds flying away
from the tree and I look at that and it
feels causal like something happened to
cause the birds to fly away from the
tree now of course the same thing can be
said something happened to cause the
boys to climb the tree and get the
apples or to cause the bears but it
seems more naturally in an environment
for a child maybe to see birds fly from
a tree
did this is where my bearing with me is
a really great thing so thank you did it
at all do you think effect the study the
nature of those images about birds
flying from the tree like a shotgun went
off or a car door slammed so for me it
feels more causal than the Bears when
swimming because XYZ it's less causal
that's an interesting observation I
think there's a few things to say about
that one is that we didn't observe any
kind of expressive language in both the
English speakers that we normed a study
on or NSL signers but suppose we had
well it's not clear having a causal
event would affect quantifier structure
because it's still shows the difference
even if something caused the birds to
fly away there wouldn't be a difference
in the size of group of birds that flew
away and what we were after was that
quantifier difference whether they
wanted to say some birds flew away or
all of the birds flew away
we have one minute left
so if you have a quick question I think
Nanyan has a question here this it may
not be a quick question but um so I'm
not very familiar with the inflexion
system of ASL but I was wondering so on
the topic of relative clauses um if we
had a more elaborate description say an
action depicted by even like with
classifiers what would happen in that
situation like because there's like more
motion involved so in terms of the like
reduced version and the relative cost
like what are the things that will be
reduced and how is that different from
say establishing an entity using space
and then referring to that entity in
space like would that be considered a
peritectic paratactic use or a relative
clause those are all great questions and
I'll try my best to answer them quickly
in terms of whether we see those kind of
shortening with other kinds of
structures or classifiers or whatever we
plan to test that we spits it
specifically did this study only using
action verbs that tended not to be using
classifiers buzz classifiers as you know
are complicated and they've got a lot of
things in them not just verbs they've
got information about the noun in them
as well and some people have argued that
these are gestural or there another
linguistic structure but your question
is a good one and we do plan to study
this to figure out how far we push this
is it only with verbs can we can it
occur with some double embedding with
subject and object linked so all of
those things are future directions and
you're on track with that and your other
question was about pointing in space and
if we would count that as parrot taxes
so the analysis of pointing is very
complicated and there's a lot of there's
not a lot of consensus in sign language
literature about what those mean in
their analyses but it's not about parrot
taxes
it's definitely anaphoric often it
refers back to something but
demonstrative definites pronouns we
don't know yet what for sure what they
are thank you so much wonderful thank
you very much okay our second speaker
will be introduced by jessica tanner
yay
hello everyone hi my name is Jessica
Tanner and this is my name sign it's so
good to see so many people here today
it's terrific so I just wanted to let
you know that I am the first ASL
lecturer here at Yale University yay
right
Bravo so maybe I'm not sure but I could
be the first deaf lecture here on
faculty I'm not sure I'm I had to do
some more research on that and find out
if I'm the first but yeah it's all good
so thank you so much to Yale University
for successfully having ASL for credit
here it's such a tremendous thing so we
want to keep that going so
congratulations to you it is my great
honor here to introduce the second
panelist today and her name is Amber
Martin
dr. amber Martin she has her PhD in
psychology and it's she's from the
University of Minnesota and that's where
she received her PhD in 2009 so now
she's a professor she's developmental
psychology from Hunter College so that's
really impressive and very nice her
research is focused on language
acquisition and how it influences how
that language deprivation has an
influence in her specific concentration
her specific concentration is on
language acquisition and a parallel with
cognition cognitive development and she
uses two different languages for her
research she uses American Sign Language
as Nicaraguan
language as well to study these and she
compares and analyzes how these the
interplay between these two languages
how I mean how these two languages she
uses these two languages to study the
interplay between these two ideas and
how this affects the language
development of children that have deaf
children in particular so I think this
is a really interesting topic are you
all really curious to find out what
she's gonna speak about today yeah so
welcome to dr. Amber Martin yeah thank
you for coming
[Applause]
good afternoon thank you so much I'm
honored to be here today and I very much
appreciate the opportunity invitation
and I welcome the opportunity to invite
you all to my campus as you just heard
dr. Koch Abbe talked about the emergence
of a new language and how it changed
over time the life of that language is a
living breathing changing thing now I'm
going to transition to talking about
language emergence and growth in
individuals how individual children
acquire language as was previously
mentioned my research looks at the
effects of language deprivation and how
that affects deaf children what are the
impacts of early language acquisition
and how does that affect cognitive
development as mentioned in the
introduction my research centers on this
question how do language and cognition
shape each other this is a very broad
question clearly so the research could
go in many directions one question I'm
interested in is about which language
you have and when you learned it how do
those things affect and shape you as a
person how do they shape the user of the
language this is an interesting question
to me
here's another question and it really is
full circle what about the user do you
as an individual language learner and
user have an influence on the language
itself the language is developing
structure so it's a cyclical question
and there's an interplay here in with a
bi-directional impact I'm going to spend
my time now talking about the first
question the language and how it
interacts with the children but again
this question does go by directionally
many of you may have some knowledge
about these statistics having to do with
language experiences of deaf children
you may know that a very small
percentage of deaf children are born
into an environment where they have full
access to a language because they have
deaf parents who use sign language we
call this group deaf of deaf or dod the
rest of deaf children 95% experienced a
wide range of linguist experiences here
in the United States there are some deaf
children born to hearing parents
typically who are not exposed to sign
language at birth hopefully that will
change over time but currently it is the
state that most hearing parents when
they have a deaf child that's usually
the first deaf person they've ever met
also among that ninety-five percent of
deaf children we see a very wide range
in language experiences there are a
variety of intervention programs
educational approaches some involving
sign language some not some focusing on
speech only and sometimes they're paired
in different ways also there are various
sign systems that children are
introduced to so it is a very
wide-ranging dynamic
what that means for deaf children in
terms of early language acquisition and
their early language experience is that
there are a variety of experiences and
the quality of those experiences differ
there's a great variation and it depends
on do they have good quality access to
language that experience varies greatly
it depends often on the quality of the
input that a child is receiving that
applies not only to spoken language but
sign language as well the quality of
input can vary and that quality of
language input depends on the skill
level of the adults in their environment
it also depends on factors that are
attitudinal about language exposure for
early children that also varies greatly
a third factor that is critical is time
of exposure the timing of a child's
first language experience and that
varies greatly among deaf children as
well
there are infants who are exposed to
language from birth whether it be a sign
language or spoken language with
cochlear implant at times the first
exposure to language that initial
experience sometimes happens far later
and from an early age to an older age
and everywhere in between there is no
profile of the deaf student or child
it varies greatly and that's been one
reason it's so difficult to study how do
we characterize deaf children and their
language experience this chart is about
spoken language trajectories for deaf
children with cochlear implants the gray
area is children who are hearing and
their trajectory the
the lines reflect deaf children what
this demonstrates is that it's all over
the map right you see a wide variety so
there's a great deal of variability here
that early language experience is
difficult to capture well as a result
many deaf children experience what we
call language deprivation we don't
actually have a standard definition
about what language deprivation means so
here's a definition it's true the
experience is extremely varied and it
makes it very difficult to characterize
those who studied deaf children do agree
that deaf students often do experience
some degree of language deprivation it's
quite common language deprivation really
means that a child was not exposed to
language that was age-appropriate and
there's a great degree of a lack of
exposure to language during the critical
language learning period
so what I just described shows the
picture of deaf children here in the
United States and the variability in
that experience now I'd like to talk
about the situation in Nicaragua and the
early language experience for deaf
children there there are some
similarities between Nicaragua and the
United States in that respect and some
differences among the similarities are
that most deaf children born in
Nicaragua have parents who don't know
sign language and who are not deaf also
in Nicaragua there is no standard there
are no standards for early intervention
they don't have programs to support
parents after they have a diagnosis in
Nicaragua the deaf children there we
know clearly that their first language
experience is not until they enter
school the age of onset of language
acquisition happens at the same time as
their entry into school so the year or
the day that they start being exposed to
language can be clearly identified
because it's clearly indicated by the
time at which they entered school in
addition children who come in to the
school there are exposed to the same
peer group and others in their
environment so they have a consistent
language exposure experience so some of
those early language experiences are
similar to those of students in the
United States but there are some areas
that are unique this brings me to my
research question how are language and
cognition interdependent and what are
the consequences
linguistically and cognitively of early
language deprivation
[Music]
so just because of the modality of sign
languages the structure spatial
structure is very rich we use space in
sign language to talk about space but
for many other reasons as well and to
express many types of grammatical
structures so automatically we see that
sign languages are very rich in what we
can do in terms of spatial information
and studying these languages we can talk
about things that are physically in our
environment and point to express that
information in shared space we also use
space for Co rent for the co referencing
so if I want to talk about two people a
teacher and a TA I can establish those
to reference in a low sigh to indicate
the two different people
but it's not only used for talking about
real things we can also use space to
talk about cognition or ideas we can
talk about comparing two ideas and how
those two ideas are interrelated we
could talk about justice for example
here on my right and freedom on my left
and talk about how those two things are
related using space also in the
syntactic structure of the language
itself in ASL there are rich uses of
space and here are some examples of that
I can say here's the teacher and the
teacher gave a paper to the TA to
distribute among the students the
directionality tells you who's doing
what to whom and also modifications can
be done to the verb using space that
modality question
is very rich because of the way sign
languages make use of signing space in
Nicaraguan sign language there are some
similarities in the way they use space
in their language and research has shown
how emergence of spatial modulation has
appeared in Nicaraguan sign language for
verbs I have a few things I want to show
you that aren't specific to Nicaragua
but other sign languages as well the way
use of space is organized can be
horizontally where we tend to place
things in space across a horizontal
plane you don't have a person up above
and down below in theory we could use a
vertical plane in weight in which to
organize that but typically that's not
the way it's done it's the horizontal
plane but we also do that for different
purposes we can use a vertical
organization to talk about things like
relative States or is that a relative
status excuse me of people so the
horizontal plane is very commonly used
so the modality-specific considerations
give us an opportunity to explore the
relationship between the use of space
and non linguistic cognitive spatial
skills and this isn't new research it's
been around for a while looking at this
question but it's a great place to start
because again of the richness of the way
sign languages use space different
studies have in fact shown that signers
use mental rotation Emery looked at this
in Prior research and my work has as
well when we see people who use sign
language who are acquiring sign language
we look at their ability to mentally
rotate the formations and that's
transformations in the linguistic domain
so now I'd like to look at this question
let's go back to the importance of age
of acquisition does that impact or does
that relationship between language and
cognition depend on the age at which a
child acquires language and when do
those benefits appear do they appear
early or does it not happen until later
at what age do they emerge also when we
talk about benefits and the use of space
and spatial cognitive skills are there
specific devices that are used in sign
languages how general are they and how
specific are those benefits that are
carried from the language to over to
cognition
we wanted to develop a mental rotation
task to look at these questions we dev
developed a tasks using computers I'll
explain what happens in the tests and
show you an example of someone actually
taking the test these shapes represent
what a participant would see on a
computer screen so they're presented
with an image and then they have the
real object that they're physically
holding and they look at two pictures
and they have to determine which one
matches the actual physical object in
front of them and it's a touchscreen so
they can respond by touching the screen
we measure response time we can also
measure accuracy how quickly can they
make those decisions importantly we are
comparing several different aspects of
the mental rotation task one is we're
looking at the plane used to compare the
mental rotation is it a horizontal plane
or is it on a different plane for
example if you're thinking about a
physical table like maybe a lazy susan
when you think about that rotation on a
horizontal plane can you mentally
represent both sides of that rotation
and can you modulate that visually in
your mind or similarly a picture moving
on a wall along two different planes of
rotation and also we use two different
types of objects a simple shape and a
human figure so we wanted to look at two
different areas where our specific
effects seen with users of sign language
when using an object versus a human
figure
this is an example of the task
for part of our analysis we looked at
the people who had early exposure to
language and we wanted to look at ASL
signers in this respect signers of ASL
native signers of ASL we also compared
them to children who learned later at
the age of three or six and we compared
them also to hearing non signers what we
found is reflected in this graph those
who learn language earlier have are
better at accuracy so the higher bars
represent greater accuracy the early
learners overall performed better than
those who learned at a later age
we also found effects of the plane
rotation overall signers did better with
rotation tasks that were horizontal than
vertical also hearing people did better
with horizontal than vertical rotation
tasks overall that was generally true
oh I'm sorry let me go back
you'll also notice here that early
language learners we see no difference
between vertical and horizontal plane
rotation those results are the same but
the late learners do better with
horizontal and not as well with vertical
which mirrors the results with their
hearing peers
also all of the groups did better with
human figures when then the block task
which was interesting something about
the shape versus the human figure that
result was consistent among all groups
what is this demonstrate it demonstrates
the importance of early language
acquisition on mental rotation skills so
language and cognition do are influenced
by the age of language acquisition those
who learn earlier perform better than
those who perform who learn later but
the deaf children who learned sign
language later still perform better on
these tasks than the hearing non signers
now to bring this back to the equation
that we originally talked about what
changes over time as a language emerges
and are there differences across cohorts
in their use of space here we looked
across cohorts of signers and we also
tested hearing people the hearing people
were included for the mental rotation
task but not language usage in terms of
sign language obviously these are the
results
okay so here you see a change over time
I'm sorry this is the mental rotation
task we see improvement across cohorts
over time with each successive cohort
performing better than the one before
also we see that all cohorts perform
better than the hearing group here we
see a different pattern it depends on
the type of rotation task that's being
performed with the human figure tasks
you'll notice the solid bars reflect
this and performance improvement is no
is observed immediately cohort one
signers do much better than the hearing
group in mental rotation tasks involving
human figures so that happens very very
quickly for the blocked task that's a
simple object not a human figure we see
that it takes longer for that
improvement to take place over time we
see a different pattern of mental
rotation skill improvement depending on
what type of mental rotation is involved
the block or the human figure also the
time at which a child enters school can
impact their mental rotation capacity so
now let's look at what changes in a
language some research has been done
about various types of space used in
sign languages here we looked at one
particular type of space usage that
changes over time so there's the x axis
that's used for verb movement
and if a signer wants to describe for
example who's doing what to whom for
example giving of a book you could use
this axis where it originates from the
signer I'm the person and the give
motion goes outward from my body across
the signing space that's what we refer
to as the z axis or you could have the
verb moving across the x-axis from right
to left in the space in front of me
where I establish to reference and the
give goes horizontally so the x axis or
the z axis can be used there's been
research and other types of sign
languages too that use the z axis very
early on in the emergence of the
language there are other languages where
it seems to emerge later so we wanted to
look at this emergence in NSL what we
did was ask people to sign different
situations the stimuli involved punching
actions and various types of verbs so
let me show you an example of what the
signing language looks like
so you notice the clear z-axis in use
here
and here you see of that horizontal axis
with body shifting using the x axis the
use of the x axis emerged more slowly
across the cohorts cohort 1 signers do
use it but we see increased usage across
cohorts 1 2 & 3 by cohort 3 the signers
are using that much more frequently now
lastly I'd like to describe what this
data shows and just see if you can
observe the use of x axis as well as how
that correlates with mental rotation
task performance and I don't have a
statistical analysis but I want you to
pay attention to those who perform well
on mental rotation tasks versus those
who don't and who tends to use the x
axis and who does not this graph shows
that people who tend to do well on
mental rotation also use X the x axis as
you can see in these bars those who
don't perform as well on mental rotation
tasks also don't typically use the x
axis so we see that those two
performances hang together and this is
not concrete evidence for a causal
relationship here but it is something
that we it is consistent with that
possibility
so what do we think is happening here
with this cycle
how does spatial language and entry into
access to that language carry over to
skills of spatial cognition and then the
interplay yet again with with the
development of the language and the
interplay between those two things what
we see is this trend the use of the
z-axis emerges very early mental
rotation skill also emerges early for
the human figure specifically and then
later we see the use of the z axis or
the x axis and then also mental rotation
abilities for other objects like the
block so we see by directionality in
these influences these emergences and
changes happen both when specific
features enter the language and how
those specific features feed cognitive
changes in its users those cognitive
changes in turn may feedback to affect
the grammar especially the spatial
aspects of the language and what we see
here is a cycle of interdependence we
see both language and cognition our Co
organized throughout the languages
development and within individual
children I'd like to thank all of the
participants and those who supported my
research work and thank you so much for
having me
thank you for a wonderful talk we have a
couple of minutes for questions and then
we're gonna break for coffee and then
come back so just a question to see
questions yes hi there
I just had a question about like
students that learn ASL and if you did
any research on the difference if they
were mainstreamed into like a public
school or if they went to a School for
the Deaf and their differences in the
recognition of space and movement yes I
don't know if specific research has
looked at the the content where children
acquire language or the context but in
terms of for example mainstream schools
versus schools for the deaf I don't know
but certainly the quality of the
language input and the richness of that
language input will contribute to
spatial and cognitive development I
don't know specific research that looks
at that in those different contexts
educationally so I don't know
I'm a grad student at Gallaudet with
them master's in sign language education
and I learned a lot here today one thing
that struck me as new was the X and
y-axis and I'm wondering how you came up
with that the idea of looking at the x
and y-axes actually started with
research and other sign languages like a
BSL and other emerging sign languages in
the world so what we wondered about is
would the same be true so Carol Padden
and Meyer and others were looking at a
BSL so we borrowed their ideas and
applied it to a Nicaraguan sign language
to look for the same patterns of
development and in fact we did see more
use of the x-axis over time in NSL and
spatial organization changed to across
the cohorts thank you
so we will have more time for questions
at the end when there is a panel
discussion so is that okay to hold on
okay so we're gonna take a 15-minute
break no longer than that just to get up
we have some coffee and tea and pastries
in a restaurant right there so get
something to drink quickly and please
come back okay
[Music]